is it such a bad deal to give the Greeks
the Elgin marbles for a little while
first of all as I say it's a totally
predictable thing uh if you become a
chair of the trustees the British Museum
and you're conservative you will feel a
disproportionate desire to send the
Elgin Marble to Greece it's so tempting
as this wonderful demonstration of right
hollery and of course George Osborne
we've learned has been negotiating this
return in the magazine I say I think
it's a rather unwise deal a deal that's
so handed in fact so far as we know that
it could have been negotiated by an
Austin Powers villain it's apparently a
deal that the British museum sends the
marbles to Athens and in return Athens
sends some Treasures that have never
before been seen in the UK that's very
nice of them I'm sure but I would have
thought that it's the likelihood of the
marbles being returned is exceptionally
small